un respiro leve para la sofocadas
administración del Primer Ministro
Richie sunac el plan para frenar la
migración irregular a través del Canal
de la Mancha propuesto por Reino Unido
recibió un importante respaldo del
tribunal superior británico al declarar
legal el envío de personas a Ruanda para
que Desde allí puedan tramitar la
solicitud de asilo
acojo con beneplácito la decisión de la
corte siempre hemos sostenido que
nuestra política de Ruanda Es legal me
complace que se haya confirmado hoy y
que sea una parte de nuestro plan para
abordar la migración ilegal
bajo la administración de Boris Johnson
la entonces ministra del interior briti
patel firmó un acuerdo con Ruanda que
supuso 144 millones de euros y
establecía que las autoridades
británicas enviarían al país africano a
gran parte de los migrantes irregulares
interceptados en el Canal de la Mancha
pero el tribunal europeo de Derechos
Humanos que rigen Reino Unido por ser
ese país signatario de la convención
Europea de Derechos Humanos frenó en
junio los primeros traslados la decisión
el lunes del alto tribunal británico fue
recibida con decepción
estamos decepcionados por el resultado
de hoy necesitamos reagruparnos y
considerar nuestros próximos pasos es un
alivio que ocho personas le hayan
anulado la decisión de ser enviadas a
Ruanda pero nuestra preocupación son
todas las cientos las miles de personas
amenazadas con ser enviadas a Ruanda en
este momento
la decisión de la justicia británica
supone una victoria parcial al gobierno
británico ante un tema que estaría lejos
de resolverse se espera que las
organizaciones de apoyo a los migrantes
recurran al tribunal de apelación o en
caso de ser necesario expongan sus
argumentos ante el tribunal europeo de
Derechos Humanos